[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTEO VALLONE: Hello everyone.
My name is Matteo
Vallone, and I work
in the Google Play
apps and games
business development team.
Welcome.
In my day-to-day
job, I work with some
of the most successful
apps and games developers,
and I always think
that there's lots
to be learned by apps
developers by looking
at how successful games
developers are built.
What are the key things
that games developers care
about when they actually
build their games for success?
In the next 30, 40
minutes I'll try
to answer that
question by showing you
some of the key metrics
that they look at
and how they go about
and optimize for them.
I will also try to extrapolate
some rules that you,
as app developers, can
take in your day-to-day job
and hopefully use to optimize
your apps and also show you
some examples of how these
learnings have been applied
by app developers successfully.
But before doing that, I
want to address the elephant
in the room right away.
Apps and games are
not exactly the same.
Actually, one key
difference is that it's
much harder to make money
on apps than it is on games.
And for the purpose
of this talk,
the main difference
here is that games
enjoy much more flexibility
when it comes to monetizing.
That's because, if
you think about it,
a game is a virtual world with
virtual currency and items.
So basically there are
endless possibilities
in terms of what games
developers can put together
as monetization mechanics,
bundles, and price points,
while app developers
have less flexibility.
They're actually limited by
the services and the goods
that they are trying to sell
within their app, and so less
flexibility, less granularity.
But there's also lots
of common ground,
and the main key thing in
common is the business model.
For most apps and games,
the business model
is a freemium model.
And if you share
that business model,
the equation you see here on
the right should always be true.
Your Cost Per Install,
your CPI, should always
be lower than the lifetime value
of the users that you bring in.
And lifetime value is a function
of retention, engagement,
and monetization.
Now, in a world where there
is more competition for user
acquisition and
store visibility,
the CPI is actually
rising for everyone,
for both apps and games.
And that means to make
this equation work,
you really need to focus
on the right side of it,
the lifetime value, and
those key metrics that
drive the lifetime value.
And among these, really, it
all starts with retention.
Retention is king.
These data from mobile
intelligence company Quettra
show you why.
These are average
retention curves of apps,
of games on the left
and apps on the right.
They are ranked by
daily active users.
So you see the blue line
represents the top 10
apps in the world by
daily active users,
the red line is top 50,
yellow line top 100,
and green line is top 5,000.
You see how better
retention always
drives better performance.
And games developers
know this very well.
They actually, before
even launching their game,
before investing in
user acquisition,
they spend a lot of
time and resources
optimizing their game
for this key metric.
This process is
called soft launching.
They launch an account
in a few test markets
or to a beta community,
and they really
spend time tracking how this
retention works for their game
and change their
games to the point
where they're comfortable with
the retention curves they see,
when they think that this
retention can support
that lifetime value equation
that I showed you before,
and so that they can
actually invest profitably
in user acquisition.
This process is very
rigorous, and it
requires a lot of
attention, but it
ensures that the
resources are only
invested in the right products.
As a matter of
fact, lots of games
get killed in this process.
Also high-visibility ones,
so actually, some of them
never see the light,
just because they
don't have good retention.
If you want to
measure retention,
you can do so with
Firebase Analytics.
You have a retention
report that shows you
not only your retention
curve on the top, but also
your retention
stats by [? cores ?]
of users that installed
your app in a given day.
So you can also track
how, as you release
newer versions of your app,
and people install them,
how retention changed
and hopefully improves
as you optimize for retention.
All right.
So lots of common ground.
Retention is king.
But I want to share with
you three key rules that you
can take from games
developers and hopefully
use to optimize your apps.
The first one is focusing
on the engagement cliff.
What I mean by
engagement cliff is
shown by the same chart I
showed you before from Quettra,
the retention curves here.
They did the thing that
I didn't like before.
If you look at, it's that
the biggest drop in retention
happens in the first seven days.
No matter how
successful the app is,
you see that that's
where retention really
drops dramatically.
After that, all curves
tend to flatten.
So really, the apps
that are doing a better
job in terms of
retention are doing
that in the first seven days.
That's where you win.
Now, depending on what
type of app you have,
your day-seven average
retention can vary.
You see here on the
right average retention,
day-seven retention, for
different categories of apps.
So it varies between 40%
for news and magazines
to 15% for photography.
But that means that between
60% and 85% of users
are lost in those
first seven days.
So clearly, lots of impact in
addressing those first seven
days.
And that's because users
download lots of apps,
and they try them.
And during those
first few experiences,
they actually decide whether
they want to keep using them.
Or otherwise they
forgot about them,
so sometimes they
uninstall them.
So really, addressing that
specific experience-- that is,
between learning about your
app, being comfortable with it,
and deciding to
actually keep using it--
is the most important part.
Games know this very well.
They actually face a very
steep engagement cliff,
which is you have to
learn how the game works.
You have to learn new rules,
you have to learn new mechanics,
you have to understand
why you should go
through all these challenges.
You need to care about it also.
And that part of the experience
is normally the tutorial.
Games spend a lot of
resources and time
optimizing the tutorial, because
they know how critical it is.
I want to play a video,
an except of a video,
that we shot with Pixelberry.
It was a very successful
game developer,
and it's particularly
good with their tutorials.
They have more than
75% of users that
start one of their tutorials
actually complete them.
So let me play the video here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Players coming in, we hit
them with story right away,
and we try and do
it in a way where
it's a little more natural.
We are cognizant that a
lot of people playing games
on mobile phones may not
want to read too much text,
so we try to ease
players into that.
But by the time they
finish our tutorial,
we're hoping that
they're already caught up
in the lives of
these characters,
and they want to learn more
about their backstories
and what's going on.
-I think it is
important to give people
kind of that sense of
progression in a game,
especially in mobile
games, because I
think with a lot of games,
you can reach a certain point
where you're just
repeating the same actions,
and you want to feel like you're
doing something different.
And I think story is a
great way of differentiating
that and saying, oh, now you're
dealing with a new villain,
or now you're dealing with
new issue that's come up.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTEO VALLONE: So they
talk about two key things.
One is the story.
The story for their
game is the key element,
the key value that
you should care
about when you play this game.
And they want to
make sure that you
start experiencing the story
from the first experience.
Why should the player
care about this game?
The second thing they
talk about is progression,
the sense of progression
that should always
be present in games.
And if you think about it,
this goes beyond the tutorial.
It's actually what a game is.
It always presents you
with a new challenge.
That challenge, though,
shouldn't be too challenging.
Otherwise, you're frustrated,
and you leave the game.
But also, it
shouldn't be too easy.
Otherwise, you get bored,
and you also leave the game.
And so games think
a lot about that,
and this is an example
of how they look at it.
Playdots, another
successful game developer,
built this chart for their
game called Two Dots.
And the chart is lots of dots,
and those dots are actually
levels in the game.
And those levels are
mapped along two variables.
One is the revenue per player
in that specific level,
and the other one is the
lapse rate in that level.
So how many people left
the game in that level?
This gives you an idea about
how frustrating and challenging
the level is and also
how actually engaging
and how much people
actually want
to spend money in that level.
By optimizing the difficulty
level of the levels--
sorry for-- below the
red line, they actually
manage to improve
not only conversion,
but also average
revenue per paying user.
So progression is
very important.
But this is very
specific to games,
so let's try to extrapolate
some learnings for apps.
Climbing the
engagement cliff is all
about recognizing that
those first seven days are
very important and
also quite difficult
for a user to go through them.
There's lots of
things happening,
and really, the value of your
app is not clear to them yet.
So the first thing
you should focus on
is finding that key feature
that, without much engagement,
provides value to the user--
something that can give them
a wow effect, or something
that can convince them
that they should stick around.
And it shouldn't require
too much for them
to actually unlock that.
So present that straight away.
The second thing is defining
those activation moments,
those things, those steps
in that engagement cliff,
that you need the
user to go through.
It could be signing
in, uploading something
about themselves,
adding some friends.
Whatever key action,
activation moment,
you need them to do to fully
unlock the value of your app
and start using it to
its full potential.
Those are the
activation moments.
You should make
sure at that point
that those are
presented gradually,
with a gradual investment
from a user perspective,
so that the user
is not overwhelmed.
They feel the sense
of progression,
they're going in
a direction, they
understand why you are asking
them to do these things,
and they're actually
gradually unlocking
the value of your app.
As part of that-- for
example, if you're
requiring them to sign in-- you
should treat that as a service.
You should show them
the value of doing that
before asking them to do it.
This is, again, in that
sense of progression
of unlocking that value,
showing them the value
first, and then asking
them to do something.
Also, if you have pay
walls, you should carefully
manage the appearance of them
in those first seven days.
Again, the user doesn't really
know exactly the full value
of your app yet.
You probably don't want to
overwhelm them and ask them
also about paying until they're
fully comfortable with the app,
and they've actually
unlocked the full value.
You can optimize along
these lines using, again,
Firebase Analytics.
The final report
here can help you.
In the final report, you
can create any custom event
that you want.
It could be signing in,
uploading a photo, whatever
process, activation moment you
need the user to go through,
can be defined in
the final reports.
And you can track how many
users start that process or task
and complete it.
So you can also put
them in a sequence
and see, as a funnel,
where the user gets stuck.
You can see how
many people started
one action, the second
action, the third action,
and identify those roadblocks
that stopped them from actually
going through all of them.
So a very powerful tool.
And now I want to show
you a couple of examples
of apps that have implemented
this rule successfully
in their app.
The first one is OkCupid.
OkCupid is a dating app.
Dating apps are a great
example of engagement cliff,
because before you can
actually use a dating app,
you have to do lots of things.
You have to sign in, you have to
write something about yourself,
you have to upload
a photo of yourself,
you have to answer some
questions in some cases,
like in OkCupid's case, and you
have to start liking people.
So lots of things.
And OkCupid recently redesigned
their whole onboarding
experience to make it more
gradual and step-by-step.
Also, they made each task
more enjoyable, skippable,
and they provided good
positive feedback to the user
as they went through these
tasks, again announcing
this sense of progression
that the user had
to feel to actually
complete these tasks.
As a result, they got 21%
better day-seven retention.
This means that after seven
days, they had 20% more users.
Same cost per install,
after seven days
they had 20% more users.
How they did this?
This is how it looked
before the redesign.
So you see they're asking you to
write something about yourself,
to upload a photo, to
answer some questions.
And this is all presented
in a series of modal windows
with no clear sequencing.
Also, if you start one of
these activities-- for example,
answering the question--
you see here on the right,
those are presented
all together.
Doesn't look very fun
to go through them.
It's quite actually
overwhelming.
This is how it looks
after the redesign.
The first and only
thing you need
to care about after
you sign in is
answering those five questions.
You have to answer
one by one, and it's
easy and nice to go
through all of them.
You swipe right to say yes,
you swipe left to say no.
Once you have completed
this task, then, only then,
you're asked to upload a photo.
You can do it or skip it,
but that's the only thing
you need to care about.
And after that, you can
start enjoying the app.
You can browse and start
getting familiar with it,
and you already have
done part of what
you need to do to actually
be able to use it.
But also, they remind
you of the other things
that you should do in
order to fully unlock
the value-- in this
case, start liking
five people so that their
algorithm can better match you
with people that you might like.
All right.
That was in one example.
The other example is Freeletics.
Freeletics is a
fitness app, and I
think that's probably the best
example of an engagement cliff.
When you download a
fitness app, you're
probably not doing fitness yet.
So the fitness app needs to
convince you to go to the gym
and actually do fitness.
It's not enough if you just
download the app, right?
So that's the first
key challenge.
The second challenge is,
when you download the app,
and you actually go to
the gym to use your app,
there might be some
time in between.
And what do you do with the app?
And in those days that
you're not going to the gym,
you might forget
about it, or you
might find another app, right?
So how do you keep users
engaged in that time frame?
And that's common
to other verticals,
but definitely fitness is
a good example of that.
Freeletics addressed
these challenges
by making sure that their
onboarding experience felt
more personal from the
first minute you started.
You're building some
key attainable goal
that is personalized
based on your input
and that you feel more empowered
to actually go and achieve.
As a result, they obtained
47% better day-one retention,
so almost 50% more users,
after the first day,
kept using the app.
How they did that?
This is how it looked
before their redesign.
So basically, you
download the app,
you get a few cards
of what the app does.
And right after, you
are asked to sign in.
And after signing
in, you're asked
to obtain their newsletter.
After that, you're
considered a registered user,
and you can start
browsing the app,
understanding what it does for
you, and taking next steps,
basically.
What they did is
introducing this.
After those first few
cards that I showed you,
the photos about the app, the
thing they do is they ask you,
are you are a male or a female?
Let's start understanding
who you are.
And once you answer
that first question,
they start personalizing
the appearance
of the rest of the screen.
So if you're a male,
you see a male picture.
If you're a female, you
see a female picture.
And then they ask you,
what's your fitness level?
They also tell you why
they're asking you this.
It's because they're
starting to know you.
They're starting
to learn about what
you care about so that they
can build your first workout
experience.
Clear value, they're
treating this information
as a service for you,
and they're giving you
a sense of progression.
Third step is what's your goal?
Do you want to lose weight?
Do you want to build muscles?
Why do you want to do fitness?
After that, only after that,
you are asked to sign in.
Now you understand the
value of signing in.
You're storing this
information, and you're
allowing them to build your
personal workout experience.
Much different than
just asking people
to sign in without knowing
why I should sign in.
Then they ask you if you want
to join their newsletter,
but again, you
understand why now.
They are going to send you
personal recommendations, based
on your goals, to your inbox.
After that, the
last thing you see
is a feedback screen
that tells you
that they're actually building
your first workout experience.
So again, it's much
more compelling
to go through the first
experience of this app,
even if you're not at the
gym, because you are doing
something in that direction.
There is a progression toward
that first gym experience.
And also, after this, you
feel that you have some goal,
and probably you are more
motivated to actually go
to the gym in and do it.
And actually, this can
be seen in the impact
that they had also on day-three
retention, which was 17% better
than the previous version.
So even after this
first experience,
people were actually
using the app more,
and that's probably
because they were
more motivated to go to
the gym and actually do
what you do with a fitness
app, which is fitness.
All right.
That was onboarding, and
hopefully at this point,
your users are
retained, onboarded,
and they understand
the value of your app,
and you want to monetize them.
The next two rules
are about that.
The first one,
embracing your app's
multiple personality disorder.
This is what I mean by that.
This is an average
revenue distribution
curve for an average game.
No matter how
successful a game is,
lots of people will
not spend a dime in it.
And even among the
ones that spend,
there are very different amounts
that they're going to spend.
A big segment might
spend very little;
a small segment might
spend lots of money.
And then there are other
segments in between.
Recognizing, understanding
what each user is going
to potentially
spend in your game;
and how they like to
spend; what is the value
perception that they have; what
is their propensity to spend;
and targeting them
based on what you
know about them with special,
custom, in-app purchase
offers-- that's the key to
achieve much better conversion
and revenue per user.
This is an example of how a
game developer looks at this.
This is Wooga, and it's
just one way to look at it.
They segment their users
along two variables.
One is progression in the
game and the other one
is spending level.
So for each segment
you see in blue,
they have a different
way to target them,
different offers that
they can trigger to
for that specific segment.
For example, if
you're a new player,
they offer you a starter pack.
Now, if you buy this, you
become an early spender.
You're not just a
new player, you're
someone who spends early.
And they try to upsell
with some other offer.
If you buy that, then you
become an early heavy spender.
You're in a different
segment now,
and they might target you
with a different offer.
If you don't buy, you
might become a mid spender,
so later in the game, they
know which steps you took,
and they will target you with
a different discounted offer
based on that segment.
If you don't buy then, you
might become a late spender,
so they will target later,
even later in the game,
with an even different offer.
That's a very simple but very
effective way to look at.
A more advanced and
complicated but very effective
way is this other
example from Space Ape.
What they do is that they
analyze their players' behavior
in those first seven days, and
they predict the lifetime value
that those users will bring
to the game for the rest
of their life in the game.
And they look at how they
spend, what they spend on,
and also how they like to spend.
And then they target them
with different offers.
By doing this, they achieve two
times better conversion then
having a one-size-fits-all
approach.
This is how it works.
Players play.
For the first seven
days, Space Ape
analyzes their behavior,
their spending pattern.
And based on their
lifetime-value models,
they predict how much value
each user will bring to the game
and how they like to spend.
And they assign each user
to a separate segment.
Here you see an example
of two segments, just
to give you an idea.
The first segment has
medium lifetime value,
but they actually spent a lot.
Only they spent in one
go, and they're not
very frequent buyers.
They might not
spend again, or they
will spend, but at a later
stage, not very frequently.
The second group, they spend
less in a single instance,
but they're more frequent.
They're going to keep
coming and spending.
So their lifetime
value is higher;
it's just that they like to
spend in a different way.
These two segments will see
different offers in the game.
The first one will
see a big bundle
with a very high price point.
Lots of value in it,
but that's the way
to convert these people.
They're not scared about
seeing a big price point,
but they also want more value,
because they're not probably
not going to come
back and spend later.
And that's what you should
focus on as a developer.
Now, the second segment will
see a much smaller bundle,
and that will make
them comfortable,
and they will probably
convert with that.
But also, the developer
knows that they will probably
come back and buy more.
So overall, their lifetime
value will be higher.
OK, let's generalize and
extrapolate some rules that you
can take as app developers.
You need to recognize
that users will
have a very different value
perception of your app.
And no matter how successful
you are, no matter how relevant
your app is, they will
have a different propensity
to spend and also a
different way to spend.
If you can recognize that,
segment your user base based
on this, and target them
with specific, custom in-app
purchase offers, then
you can definitely
achieve a much better
conversion and revenue per user.
You can use again
Firebase to do that.
First of all, you can
use Firebase Analytics
to build segments exactly like
the one I showed you before.
Here we use it to build a high
lifetime value segment that
actually has a very
small single price
point but frequent
purchase behavior,
and a medium lifetime
value segment
that has a high single
price point but not frequent
spend behavior.
This is all done with
Firebase Analytics
using events and attributes
that the users have.
And based on this, you can
track how they perform.
Any chart in Firebase
Analytics will show you
these two different
segments and how they behave
so you can better study them.
But now what you
can do, you can also
target them with different
offers using remote config
in Firebase.
The way it works, for
example, let's say
you sell a subscription.
You're a newspaper
or a fitness app,
and you sell a subscription.
For the first segment, the one
with high single spend points
but not very frequent,
you can build a promotion
for your annual subscription.
These guys are comfortable
spending a lot,
but they don't want to
be bothered every month.
They will buy an annual
subscription probably,
so you can have a heavily
discounted annual subscription
for them.
And for the other group
with a higher lifetime
value but single
price point lower,
you can have a discount
on a monthly subscription.
So the price point
will be lower,
but they're more
comfortable doing that,
and you can target
them with this offer.
Again, it's very easy to
do this with remote config.
And you don't need to code.
You just need to go
through the options,
and it will be very easy.
This works on in-app
purchases for virtual goods.
It also works for
physical goods.
So if you have an
e-commerce app, for example,
this example applies to you.
This is Wish, a very
successful e-commerce app.
And they basically,
in their screen,
they show products to
users that they think
they might want to buy.
And they also apply
the same concept.
They show less expensive
items to users that
have shown less engagement.
Maybe they haven't
bought anything yet,
they started using the
app, or they're just not
that much engaged.
And once they see that the
users are more engaged,
they spend maybe
a couple of times,
they start showing them
more expensive products.
Again, this proves
that it works.
As a result, they obtained
10% better conversion.
All right.
The last rule is
selling umbrellas
where and when it rains.
It's basically not only about
what you sell, umbrellas,
but when and where
you sell them.
So the best way to describe
them, to describe this example,
is showing you
what Playdots does.
They recently redesigned their
old in-app purchase flow,
and as a result they
obtained 10% better revenue
per active user.
So without changing
their user base,
they got 10% better revenues
just by redesigning along
these lines.
And I'll show you
what I mean here.
So the first thing, when
you start a new level,
you see how many boosters
you have available for you.
And they give you
one button that you
can use to purchase whatever
boxes or boosters you
need to finish that level.
So you don't have to go
in the store in the game
and buy what you think you might
need; they prompt you to buy
before you start the level
exactly what you need, and they
show you what you already have.
Similarly, when you die
in a level-- in this case,
you're running out of
movess-- they show you
another call to action
that says, why don't you
buy those extra five
moves that you need
to finish the game, the level.
So you don't have
to quit the game,
go to the store in the
game, and buy what you need.
You can buy it
now, without having
to quit the level that you're
actually trying to finish.
By only doing this, they
got 6% more paying users
by just adding these
two calls to action.
The other thing they did is
they moved some in-game items
that you can purchase right
into the UI of the game.
So again, you don't
have to quit the game.
You can buy them as
you play, whenever
you want, with one tap.
They're always there.
By doing that, they got
5% better average revenue
per user.
So really, it's all about making
purchasing easy, accessible,
but also relevant-- positioning
those in-app purchases,
those products that you're
selling, exactly where you
think that the user
will need them,
and triggering
calls to action when
you think that those
are the most relevant
so that users are more
compelled to actually purchase.
The best example to show
how this works in an app
environment is TomTom.
Last year, they moved
from a premium model,
so you just had
to pay for the app
to use the app, to freemium.
And in that transition, they
got 2.4 more paying users.
And that's because they
thought very carefully
about their business
model, and they really
implemented very
well, especially
along the lines of the rule
that I described to you before.
This is how it looks.
It's very similar to the
game I showed you before.
You have 75 kilometers
to use the app for free.
After that, you have to upgrade.
And upgrading means
that you're basically
buying what they used to
sell before as a premium app.
What they did is that they
positioned that Upgrade button
in the UI of the app,
and it's always there.
No matter where you are,
it's always one tap away.
You also see the countdown
of those free kilometers
that you still have.
So you also feel the urgency of
upgrading if you're running out
of kilometers.
Very easy, very relevant.
The other thing they did is they
introduced some calls to action
when they thought you would
need to upgrade the most.
For example, you
start a new trip,
and they know that
you will run out
of kilometers during that trip.
They tell you, why don't you
upgrade now instead of doing it
while they're driving?
You might not have a connection.
So really, when you
start an activity
that they know is more
likely to convert you,
they prompt you to do it.
Second, of course, they
show you that call to action
when you're actually running out
of kilometers, or you ran out.
So those little things
actually add up,
and they're the ones
that really make
a freemium model successful.
Another example,
a bit more simple
and maybe more
applicable in most cases,
is the subscription example.
If you sell a subscription,
normally with a subscription,
you'll unlock different
features and content.
And yes, you can offer
that in your app,
and you can have a
list of all the things
that that subscription unlocks.
But also, showing the
content and the feature
in the flow of the app
that are behind a pay wall,
and prompting the
user to upgrade
when they're actually
trying to access those,
is very impactful.
This is what Busuu does.
It is a language-learning
app, and their subscription
basically unlocks more
content and more languages.
And they started putting these
calls to action with a button
to actually go into
the purchase flow
when you're trying to
access that content
and those languages that
are behind the pay wall.
And you see the result
here-- 30% better conversion
with the premium content
and 83% better conversion
with the languages.
So very impactful.
All right, to wrap up, the
three rules we talked about
are climbing the
engagement cliff, which
is all about focusing
on those seven days
after the user has
installed the app,
understanding that those are the
key moments where the user is
still not comfortable
with your app,
defining the activation moments
you need them to go through,
and making sure that those
are presented gradually
in the experience in
the first seven days
so that they are
not overwhelmed,
they feel a sense
of progression,
they understand why they're
doing what they're doing,
and they hopefully fully
unlock the value of your app
so that they might stick
around for much longer.
The second rule is about
embracing your app's
multiple personality disorder.
Freemium model is all
about lots of users
wanting different things
and having different value
perceptions.
Being able to segment them,
understand what they want,
and target them based on their
segments will help you improve
your conversion in a much
more effective way than using
a one-size-fits-all approach.
The third rule we
talked about is
selling umbrellas where
and when it rains,
which means that it's
not only about what you
sell, but also how you sell it.
And it makes a big
difference, making sure
that the in-app purchases
are presented in an easy way
to access them, always at
least one or two taps away
from purchasing, and also
triggering those calls
to action when you think
those in-app purchases are
most relevant for the user.
So that was it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]